it's the Romantic tale that could help
save Trump's tale Donald Trump's legal
entanglements hanging over the Iowa cus
caucuses today whoops as we learn more
about the spicy allegations of A Love
Affair in one of the cases against the
express fton County district attorney
Fanny Willis accused of having an
improper romantic relationship with a
top Pro prosecutor she brought in to
work on the election interference case
in Georgia it allegedly resulted in
financial gains for both of them in the
form of lavish lavish whatever vacation
the two went on using funds his firm
received for working the case Willis
breaking her silence on the allegations
in the church but only to play the race
card you did not tell me as a woman of
color it would not matter what I did my
motive my talent my ability and my
character would be constantly attacked
first thing they
say oh she going to play the race car
now but no God if isn't it them who's
playing the race card when they only
question
one so judge okay this this prosecutor
Wade he has little prosecution
experience he was like a municipal judge
handled mainly traffic violations he is
a divorce lawyer he was held in contempt
last year in his own divorce case he's
making 250 bucks an hour there's an
argument that that's 100 bucks more than
an actual expert gets paid it's been
paid 700 Grand and yet this is about rap
how you know what a surprise well you
know I got to first of all I think it's
fascinating that Fanny Willis the da in
Atlanta decides that the first time
she's going to respond to allegations of
having an affair with this guy is in
church where she doesn't deny it I think
one of her better quotes is she says she
admits she's as flawed as they come you
quote you cannot expect a black woman to
be perfect and save the world okay so
she accus accuses people of picking on
her and her alleged lover uh when there
were three prosecutors she brought on
and they only picked on the one who is
also black the only difference is the
only one she allegedly had the affair
with was a black guy not the two other
white guys you know what I'm tired of
race being used as a prophylactic for
immorality for incompetence or for
wrongdoing but here's the real problem
as a DA you have the opportunity to
bring in a special counsel a special
prosecutor if there is a conflict of
interest of some sort you want to avoid
the appearance of impropriety was that
the case here no so why did she bring
him on was it that she didn't have
enough Adas no was it because Rico which
is what Donald Trump and many of those
codefendants are charged with was
something she had no experience with no
so none of these reasons are reasons for
him to for her to bring on this guy so
you have to want a civil attorney who
ran a traffic court uh who never tried a
felony case never did a RICO case is
making
$6,000 from the federal government and
the amazing part of it is he goes to the
White House three times he goes to the
White House three times to meet with
White House councel in 2022 in May and
November of 2022 and he meets with the
Democratic heads of the January 6
committee uh Committee in the same year
here in lies the rub though they go on
cruises together they're having an
affair she is reaping Financial benefits
after giving him money for a job that he
was not qualified for that she didn't
need help for it's a scam and she should
be disbarred you know Jessica she
accuses uh uh the media or the critics
of racism for focusing on this gentleman
and not because of the affair but
because of his skin color could you just
as easily say that she's racist for not
having affairs with the white
prosecutors and in instead only having
an affair with the black one that
strikes me as racist yeah she should go
for Floyd the RICO expert uh who is on
her group of uh special prosecutors um
no I think the race card here obviously
out of line to use that for this and it
undoubtably looks bad it doesn't change
the fact that Donald Trump was indicted
by a grand jury and his co-conspirators
as well he wasn't indicted by fie Willis
and Nathan Wade so we have to keep our
eye on the prize in that sense um the
report about him being paid more than
Floyd who is this King Rico expert um
apparently the contract that Wade had it
only went on for a year currently they
are being paid the same fonnie Willis
spoke about that as well when she was
yeah yeah now right now so they're being
paid the same amount um but again when
people look at this they are going to
pay attention to the affair more than
the nuts and bolts of the campaign and
this is what Donald Trump I shouldn't
say the campaign the trial this is what
Donald Trump wants he has gone after
either the da or the judge in every case
that he has pending except for Eileen
Cannon um in Florida who he loves and
who he appointed and undoubtedly his
supporters are going to Rally about this
but I would tell everyone you've got to
pay attention to the fact that this was
a grand jury that indicted him and his
co-conspirators many of whom have
already pled guilty to what they did you
know Jesse uh once again the use of the
race car is a way to scare people away
from investigating corruption sounds a
bit like Harvard don't you think yeah
yeah Jack Smith's pretty white Jessica I
mean no one's gone after Jack Smith
harder than Donald Trump guys what is a
lily pad are lily pads even white no I
think they're green I think they're
green as a lily flower whatever the
point is that allegedly Fanny hired the
man she was having sex with to prosecute
Trump and then handed him a bunch of
money which they used on steamy
vacations to the Caribbean that's called
a sexual Kickback and then this guy has
no qualifications he was like a personal
injury attorney you know he's like have
you fallen and slipped and hit your head
at work call 1 1800 get even this guy
has no credibility and then he goes to
the White House meets with the White
House Council and builds the White House
why is he colluding with Biden's White
House and the local prosecution when the
Biden White House said this is all being
done independently Fanny's going to the
White House she's hanging with kamla
they're conspiring with Adam Shi on the
prosecution the whole thing's blowing up
in everyone's face and then this guy
Wade walks out of his office with a
handgun the very next day what kind of
attitude is that imagine Ken star was
flashing a pistol while he was coming
out of a courthouse Prosecuting Bill
Clinton that'd be the front page story
in every newspaper on Earth Jessica this
thing's falling apart just like the one
in New York's falling apart just like
all of them are falling apart yeah I
don't think Stormy Daniels and what
happened in Fon County are comparable
yeah I do because keep going it I will
you just know that if you pointed out
the gun aspect you would also be called
racist right oh because he's black
holding a gun Dana will this allegation
hurt uh uh what's her name again Fanny F
chances Willis F I call her
fny it's F spell Fanny but pronounced
fonnie okay so she when when this all
first came out she had people in Georgia
on the Republican side saying look she's
pretty credible person like we got to be
taking her seriously and if you're going
to come after Donald Trump and 18 other
people you better have a pretty airtight
case and you better keep your nose clean
she didn't and so now the credibility
angle is out the window for her and then
she adds insult to injury by saying it's
because of the race card so I don't
think it's going to be good it's not
this case is not getting as much
attention as it would if there weren't
the caucuses and the weather um but if
this were a Republican uh da and caught
up in this it would be on the front page
of everything just like the big protest
on Saturday night against Biden at the
White House doesn't get any attention
but if she were on the other foot it
certainly would MH that Evacuate the
what do you call it the non vital
Personnel or something like that not
news all right up next it's the
countdown to the Iowa caucuses I hear
it's cold there and we have Fox News
voter analysis that you will not see
anywhere else hey everyone I'm Emily
compano CCH me and my co-hosts Harris
vulner and Kaye mcki on outnumbered
every weekday at 12:00 p.m. Eastern or
set your DVR also don't forget to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
for daily highlights